le département vous présente terre de
trail entourée de remparts le piton des
neiges n'est pas seulement le spot du
grand raid c'est aussi l'habitat
d'oiseaux unique au monde que richard
est aisé qui protège au quotidien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour montebourg charme lieu chargé de
mission environnement dans l'association
avait eu deux heures c'est l'association
pour la valorisation l'antre de monde
donc on fait des actions de protection
pour protéger les pétrels et les plus
fins de la réunion ou abba l'on pense à
gallargues un panier pour être dit qu'on
va t'on mettre en place un dispositif de
dératisation vu que balaiera c'est un
des prédateurs du pétrole bas vas-y on
voit donc tous les tous les quarante pas
pour faire à peu près 30 mètres de
distance entre chaque boîte parce que le
domaine vital tu du rat noir c'est
trente mecs on commence par un voileux
vous concentrer là à l'exil tu sais que
tous les grands raids commence comme un
premier pas sûr
[Musique]
vous faites quoi c'est là où il termine
est terminée on va ramasser les déchets
utilisés la dératisation
mais quel rapport avec la protection des
oiseaux là alors du coup là on est en
périphérie hockey des zones de colonies
donc c'est vraiment un accès rapide sur
le bras des étangs qui est juste plus
aulas vient plutôt des neiges et du coup
bah si on n'élimine pas les prédateurs
ils peuvent rentrer ses colonies là le
matin quand je me réveille je sais que
les actions qu'on va mener sur le
terrain que mes équipes vont mener aussi
sur le terrain ça va permettre de
protéger le patrimoine de la réunion
donc de rendre les milieux plus propre
en ramassant les déchets et à des
déchets à des rats du coup mais en fait
de la lutte contre le rat et la lutte
conte le chat arrêts c'est un chat
domestique qui retrouvait à l'état
sauvage du court et on appelle shaaré et
donc c'est les deux principaux
prédateurs des pétrels de la réunion et
on vérifie quand même la sensibilité de
la cage aux antilles à part à payer un
souci au niveau de la trappe si elle est
assez sensible et si l'ag à peine
clichés et ça s'est déclenchée
pour un titre indicatif est à peu près
80 chats qu'on récupère en périphérie
des zones de colonies sur nos zones
d'intervention du pilat fin 2012 on a
commencé activités en 2014 bon on
travaille avec eux des contrats aidés
que le mot d'ordre de l'association
madame le soudan l'association c'est
l'accession au chevet de l'environnement
c'est la légende du colibri en fait un
feu dans une forêt et le colibri lui il
m'a fait des kilomètres et des
kilomètres pour prendre une petite
goutte d'eau et le ramener sur le feu de
forêt et un autre oiseau qui le dit mais
pourquoi tu fais ça sert à rien et le
colibri lui réponds bah mais si tout le
monde faisait quelque chose
le feu s'éteint après donc tu fais ta
part donc moi je fais ma part dans
l'environnement alors que tu envie de
dire richard à tous les coureurs qui
veille sur 30 placés pour greg la base
de déchets si possible quoi parce que
bon là vous avez vu il ya des zones et
non loi des colonies et s'il ya des
déchets il alors après y avait chaque
donc ramassa de biche et ne laissez pas
traîner
c'est à dire que course au pétrole comme
toi tu penses au contraire quand tu en
voilà merci en tout cas à merci pour son
action et le merci pour les pétrels
mourir rien or
le département vous a présenté terre de
trail